how's it going y'all today we have an
award-winning portable monitor from our
friends at asus this is the asus rog
xg16a hp slash w did i get it right oh
she got it right
that comes with 144hz refresh rate and
many other cool features so let's get
into it
[Music]
to kick things off there are a ton of
accessories that come with the monitor
the first thing you'll notice when you
open up the box is this nifty little bag
that comes with a lot of little pockets
here and there to keep all of the cables
and power cables so that you can run
this monitor we have a usbc to hdmi
a usb-c to usbc
a usb-c to usb-a
and lastly we have a usb c to usb
adapter and yeah you can basically hook
it up to any devices you have whether
it's a phone a ps5 an xbox a laptop
anything which makes this monitor super
versatile next up is the rg tripod stand
which is a quick release system so that
you can tear down and set up your
monitor as you will and it's super easy
to use it also allows you to tilt the
screen from 180 degrees to 90 degrees it
can even be viewed top down which is a
nice little touch if you ever need that
if you don't feel that lugging around
the stand you can leave that stand at
home because it has a stealthy af
kickstand at the back to keep it upright
only thing i need to notice that you
need to remove the mount at the back in
order to get to the kickstand the mount
at the back is a proprietary mount
system that's only meant for the tripod
which means unfortunately you can't
mount it on any arm but hey the
portability and the small form factor
are the real stars here it's super light
at 900 grams and is only 11.8
millimeters thick making it super slim
and light to carry around and it also
comes with front facing speakers with an
embedded ess amplifier dac
and yeah it's pretty impressive it'll
definitely do the trick if you want to
play games with your friends or if
you're trying to show like a showcase
real to your clients but if you're
looking for a more robust seamless and
comfortable audio experience check out
what our friends at logitech have to
offer here at geek culture audio is a
huge part of our daily lives both work
and play so what's our choice of
headphones well meet the logitech g435
lightspeed wireless gaming headset it
allows you to listen to all the rich
sounds from your music videos and games
across pc console and mobile while
spotting some popping vibrant colors not
only that it weighs just 165 grams which
means sometimes you even forget that
you're wearing it with a robust battery
life of 18 hours you can enjoy your
gaming sessions for prolonged periods of
time for more details head over to
logitechg.com
like i said before it has 144hz refresh
rate which is amazing for gaming and it
is nvidia g-sync compatible it has three
hours of battery life on its 7800mah
battery
and if you're in a tiff you can charge
it for an hour and it will give you two
hours worth of gaming which is pretty
damn handy of course if you're doing
some content creation a bit of admin
work or whatever it may be it will last
much longer it's 15.6 inches wide and
100 rgb thanks to its ips lcd panel
which means you have more than enough
real estate to feast your eyes on in
stunning color and sharpness and it
comes with a bunch of visual options
such as game plus adaptive sync game
visuals and shadow boost game plus gives
you cross hairs an fps counter and even
a timer and shadow boost helps to expose
the darkest areas in game dynamically
now even though this monitor is under
the republic of gamer's name it has so
much potential outside of gaming which
i'll get into you fellow video editors
out there will be spoiled just to bring
this out because having that second
screen to view your video panel and
using your laptop screen to view the
timeline always helps same thing goes
for your graphic designers out there i
imagine that having more space will be a
killer deal for the peeps in the office
tutors and even students out there
impress your clients and peers by
bringing this bad boy out for your
presentations be the coolest fellow at
your local cafe while you work or bring
this out while you're camping to watch
movies i don't know there are so many
situations where a monitor like this
would come in handy but of course for
the gamers especially you mobile gamers
out there hook up your laptop or your
mobile phone to this monitor and get
busy fragging in glorious 144 hertz
however your phones need to have dp alt
mode in order to use them with the
monitor minimalist folks would
definitely appreciate the white on this
unit and how space efficient it is if
you are using a monster monitor at home
with these specs the asus rog xg16hp
w would serve as a nice space friendly
alternative personally it's really handy
to have around especially when i need to
crush your edits on the same day at the
event venue because having that second
screen makes it that much more conducive
because i don't need to fumble with
premiere pro's ui or lightroom's ui
because i can ship things around so it
makes everything that much more
comfortable and productive all in all
it's a little bit pricey but if you're
looking for performance on the go
display customization options and
orientation versatility to boot this is
exactly what you're looking for though i
have to say that since it's built it's
mostly plastic and the tripod is a
little heavy
some degree of care is needed when
handling it but that's why it's so
lightweight and why the stand is so
sturdy so i can't really complain that's
all we have for this video make sure you
guys follow all of our socials like and
subscribe to us we have a steady flow of
content waiting just for you and with
that i'll talk to you guys soon take
care
[Music]
you